the streets are painted red and security
has been stepped up ahead of China's
Communist Party Congress beijing's
tightened covid-19 curbs as well any
outbreak during this important political
event would be an embarrassment for the
government of course people are paying
attention to you know whether there will
be changes or short-term changes uh
because it is affecting everybody it's
affecting the entire nation while the
rest of the world has mostly decided to
live with the virus China has doggedly
pursued its zero covert approach heaping
pressure on the economy
Shoring up growth will be a top priority
for the new leadership
many people will be keeping a close eye
on the new economic lineup you are
talking about a very very profound major
Personnel changes in China the
personality of different leaders at
different levels do have Major Impact
among those on their way out are Premier
League who manages the world's second
largest economy and Lil Herb president
xi's top economic advisor both as seen
as pro-market reformists it's hard to
say who could step in to fill those
shoes decision making for the leadership
reshuffle are made behind closed doors
but many political analysts believe
incoming candidates will be she
loyalists with a more state-driven
economic approach
another question is whether the
reshuffle will throw up any potential
successor to Xi Jinping
some fear the president's consolidation
of power May divert attention away from
the most pressing problem
the economic problem seems to have been
cast aside Beijing is now focusing on
the power shift and the establishment of
a totalitarian system I believe China's
economy in the long run will find it
difficult to escape from the prospect of
recession
to prevent that from happening an
overhaul of China's covid-19 policy
could be crucial but there's little
indication as it stands of any
significant change Patrick Frank Al
Jazeera Beijing